Hallo ihr Lieben!
Heute gibt's endlich die gewünschte Regenbogentorte, die habt ihr euch schon extrem lange gewünscht.
Und letztens kurz bevor ich einkaufen gegangen bin bei Kaufland
hab ich noch schnell einen Fragensticker bei Instagram gemacht um euch zu fragen:
Was möchtet ihr eigentlich? Soll die aufwendig sein?
Soll man von außen sehen, dass es eine Regenbogentorte ist?
Und ihr habt eigentlich fast einstimmig entschieden, dass sie von außen nicht erkennbar sein soll.
Das heißt außen wird sie weiß werden und vielleicht so ein paar Streusel mit rein nehmen,
das entscheide ich spontan.
Und innen dann kunterbunt und sie soll ohne Fondant sein und komplett anfängerfreundlich.
Und genau so mache ich das auch, hab jetzt hier die ganzen Zutaten eingekauft.
Und ich lege direkt los mit dem Teig. Das muss jetzt natürlich ein heller Teig sein,
wir färben den nämlich gleich schön ein.
Und ich mache heute den sogenannten Wunderkuchen.
Dafür nehmen wir uns Eier, die habe ich jetzt hier schon in der Rührschüssel meiner Küchenmaschine
und geb da Zucker und Vanille mit dazu.
Und das schlagen wir dann richtig schön hell-cremig, das dauert so ungefähr 4 bis maximal 5min.
In die hell-cremige Eiermasse geben wir dann Apfelsaft und Rapsöl,
ihr könntet auch Sonnenblumenöl verwenden.
Und generell findet ihr alle genauen Mengenangaben hier unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Und jetzt mache ich mich an die trockenen Zutaten. Da haben wir Mehl und Backpulver,
das einmal vorab miteinander verrühren, dann verbindet sich das besser im Teig.
Und jetzt in einem Schwung mit zur Masse sieben, das ist ganz wichtig.
Gebt das einmal komplett rein und dann nur ganz kurz unterrühren, bis es sich verbunden hat
und dann können wir den Teig auch schon einfärben.
Und den fertigen Teig dann ganz einfach durch 6 teilen, am besten nehmt ihr euch ausreichend große Schüsseln
und eine Suppenkelle oder irgendwas vergleichbares damit ihr immer die gleiche Menge habt.
Und anschließend mit Gelfarben, das ist das Beste weil die flüssigen Farben würden die Konsistenz
des Teigs verändern und mit Gelfarben macht ihr einfach nichts falsch.
Die gebt ihr dann da rein in den Regenbogenfarben, ich hab jetzt genommen
Blau, Violett, Grün, Rot Gelb und Orange. Orange hatte ich als Farbe so nicht da,
deswegen mischt einfach Gelb und Rot, und dann bekommt ihr Orange.
Und jetzt fange ich an zu rühren und dann: It's magic! Dann verwandelt sich der Teig.
So und jetzt geht's ans Ausbacken. Wir haben ja jetzt hier 6 Böden insgesamt
und da wir alle 6 einzeln backen habe ich mir gedacht, ich mach jetzt die Torte etwas kleiner
und zwar mit einem Durchmesser von 20cm. Ich hab jetzt hier auch meine Springform,
ihr könntet auch Tortenringe nehmen z.B.
Und dann kann ich eben immer 2 auf einmal backen weil es ist nicht gut für den Teig,
wenn er sehr lange steht. Also er sollte schon zügig weiterverarbeitet werden,
also gebacken werden aber so beeile ich mich jetzt und dann ist das auch gar kein Thema.
Schiebt immer eins nach dem anderen rein, bzw. immer zwei.
So und ich fange jetzt an mit Grün und Lila und dann backe ich die bei 180° C Ober- und Unterhitze -
Wichtig: immer den Ofen vorheizen! - für ca. 15min, länger brauchen sie auch nicht.
Während die Böden abkühlen machen wir jetzt die frische Creme und dafür schlage ich vorab Sahne steif.
Das funktioniert am besten, wenn die Sahne ganz kalt ist. Lasst ein  bisschen Sahnefest einrieseln
und dann gebt ihr das kurz an die Seite und wir verrühren die anderen Zutaten miteinander.
Das ist hier einmal Mascarpone, dann nehme ich noch Quark mit dazu, das gibt so ein bisschen Leichtigkeit.
Natürlich Puderzucker für die Süße und für die Frische Zitronenschalenabrieb,
da nehmt ihr am besten eine Bio Zitrone.
So, das hab ich jetzt auch nur kurz verrührt, gebe da jetzt noch ein bisschen Sahnefest mit dazu
weil Quark eben nicht so fest ist. Mascarpone bräuchte prinzipiell gar kein Sahnefest
aber weil wir eben Quark haben, mache ich das jetzt nur mal zur Sicherheit.
Rühre das gut um und dann mit ganz viel Liebe mit einem Teigschaber - ihr kennt's - einmal die Sahne unterheben.
So, jetzt ist die Creme fertig und ihr könnt sie jetzt entweder einfach so drauf spritzen
oder ihr füllt sie euch in einen Spritzbeutel. Das mache ich so,
damit ich überall immer gleich viel Creme habe. Ihr könnt das auch natürlich einschätzen,
das ist gar kein Problem. Und damit jetzt auch nochmal ein bisschen mehr Fruchtigkeit mit reinkommt
und es trotzdem hell bleibt, nehme ich Aprikosenkonfitüre.
Ich hab sie kurz in der Mikrowelle erwärmt, dann wird sie richtig schön flüssig.
Und jetzt verfahrt ihr einfach so, dass ihr den Boden mit der Aprikosenkonfitüre tränkt,
mit der Creme füllt, bis ihr beim letzten Boden angekommen seid.
Und dann schließt ihr mit Creme ab und dann zeige ich euch, wie's weitergeht.
So, jetzt habe ich alles komplett befüllt und eingestrichen,
und die oberste Schicht einmal mit der Sahnecreme versiegeln
damit eben der letze Boden auch nicht austrocknet.
Jetzt könnt ihr die Torte für ½h kühlen, falls es bei euch in der Küche irgendwie total warm sein sollte.
Ich muss es jetzt nicht weil die Creme ist schon sehr fest und wir haben jetzt zügig gearbeitet,
daher entferne ich jetzt den Tortenring.
Das macht ihr normalerweise ja mit dem Backformlöser. Mit dem kurzen, das klassische, das kennt ihr.
Das klappt jetzt nicht weil die Torte ist schon ziemlich hoch,
ich zeig euch auch später so eine Anschneidtechnik,  die ich für mich entwickelt hab.
Und die werdet ihr jetzt einmal mit dem Tortenringmesser XXL
befreien die Torte.
(H: Wooow!)
Das ist tatsächlich ganz neu und ich benutze es jetzt auch in dem Video zum ersten Mal,
daher einmal am Rand rein
(H: Das war jetzt meine Werbestimme!)
Seine Werbestimme meldet sich! So, einmal vorsichtig hier am Rand rein mit der Klammer hinten dran
und dann am Rand entlang fahren.
(H: Genial!)
Das Tolle ist, dass ich eben jetzt gerade so in dieser Position bin mit unseren Herstellern
dass ich neue Produkte entwickle, dass ich sie realisieren kann
und die eben dann bei uns im Onlineshop anbieten kann.
Und das ist eben eines der Produkte, ihr habt gerade auch schon das andere gesehen
aber das zeige ich euch so in den nächsten Videos nach und nach.
(H: Warum so bescheiden Kiki? Das ist eine Weltneuheit!)
Ja, das ist tatsächlich eine Weltneuheit, ja!
(H: Woanders werdet ihr das nicht finden.)
Ihr werdet das tatsächlich nicht finden außer bei uns!
So, und jetzt einmal den Tortenring vorsichtig entfernen und da darf jetzt auch nichts - ja, perfekt!
Also da ist jetzt auch nichts gerissen.
Und jetzt nehmen wir uns die restliche Creme - ich find's eigentlich so schon mega schön!
(H: Richtig krass!)
Also Naked Cake Charakter irgendwie!
Aber wir machen's so weil ihr wolltet jetzt eine helle.. außen eine helle Creme,
ihr habt gesagt man soll eigentlich nicht sehen, dass sich eine Regenbogentorte drunter versteckt.
Daher einmal rundherum einstreichen!
(H: Ich find das aber so schon geil!)
Sieht schon geil aus!
(H: Also ich find das so schon.. ich find das so schon richtig cool, ganz ehrlich!)
Sieht echt cool aus. Also wer jetzt keine Lust mehr hat, der lässt das so!
(H: Also ich würd das so lassen! Alleine auch weil ich jetzt zu faul bin, das noch einzustreichen!)
Mit der restlichen Creme dekoriere ich jetzt noch die Oberfläche der Torte
und ich habe euch tatsächlich wiedermal auf Instagram gefragt -
ich hab diese Torte eigentlich nur mit euch kreiert - ob ich außen irgendwas buntes, irgendwie Streusel oder so,
irgendwas buntes noch drüber streuen soll oder ob ich gar nichts machen soll, dann ist sie komplett weiß.
Oder ob ich weiße Streusel nehme. Und der Großteil hat tatsächlich gesagt:
Lass sie außen weiß, damit auch das Geburtstagskind eventuell
total überrascht ist, was da auf einmal für bunte Farben rauskommen.
Und mir gefällt's auch richtig gut muss ich sagen, ich hab's jetzt komplett weiß gelassen
und ich schreib euch auch die ganz genauen Mengenangaben
wie immer unten in die Videobeschreibung. Nachher seht ihr auch noch,
wie ich die Torte anschneide, diese hohen Torten.
Und dann lassen wir sie uns schmecken und verteilen auf jeden Fall den Rest,
weil hier hat leider keiner Geburtstag!
Euch wünsche ich jetzt ganz viel Freude beim Nachmachen,
schreibt mir unbedingt in die Kommentare was ihr euch als nächstes wünscht
und dann machen wir das. Ne, Hamza?
(H: Auf jeden!)
Auf jeden Fall. So, bis zum nächsten Mal auf Kikis Kitchen.
Tschüss!